hey 42 here this video is sponsored by
Squarespace Squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
humans are a resilient Bunch we've lived
through an Ice Age defeated the violent
and unforgiving wilderness and sent man
into outer space but in the end we could
be defeated by a creature that we can't
even see bacteria we all worry about
threats such as nuclear war terrorism
and worst of all a growing army of
militant snowflakes but could it be a
global pandemic that wipes out humanity
for good the World Health Organization
has added disease X to its list of
concerns that posed a serious threat to
all of humanity disease X what I've
never heard of that that's because it
doesn't exist yet disease X is the wh
OHS catch-all name for the next big
disease epidemic the next plague we
don't know where it will come from or in
what format but there's an almost 100%
chance that it will come at some point
Homo sapiens have already faced some
truly horrific genocide all viruses
throughout our history first came the
black death that killed as much as 60%
of Europe's population then smallpox and
the Spanish flu but has our deadliest
foe yet to rear its morbid head
possibly what would a humanity
destroying disease X need to look like
to be effective which symptoms would it
need to kill every person alive the
answer is not at all the perfect disease
would need to have no visible symptoms
to ensure maximum for ality humans avoid
people who appear visibly sick subtle
symptoms such as inflamed red nose and
sinuses or coughing and sneezing are a
clear sign when he passes by to clear
off any obvious symptoms would encourage
people to keep their distance from the
infected and so the virus would have a
harder job spreading a disease that had
no symptoms would have an immediate
upper hand over humanity from the get-go
if the common cold was symptomless a
considerably higher number of people
would catch it each year but then if it
was symptomless it wouldn't really
matter but what if that symptomless
virus vested in your system for two
weeks before reaching a critical mass of
infection level where your body has no
choice but to give up and shut down that
would be the ultimate mass murdering
virus because any disease which poses a
hope of wiping out humanity would need a
very long incubation period this is the
time it takes a virus to multiply in
your system from the moment of initial
infection to a point where it has enough
of a command over your body that it can
start to take effect if the incubation
period of this mystery virus was between
one to three days
it would be almost impossible for it to
wipe out the human race it wouldn't make
it very far at all as soon as the first
victim dies then the international
organizations such as the CDC would
quickly step in to quarantine that area
as happened with the 2014 West Africa
Ebola outbreak in such scenarios to CDC
creates a perimeter around the patient
zero and that perimeter is dependent on
the virus's incubation period or time to
kill and today the perimeter required to
contain certain viruses can be
accurately modeled using computer
algorithms once some key details are
known about the virus the longer the
incubation period the further it can
spread throughout a country or noticed
with an incubation period of only a few
days it could be contained with relative
ease by putting travel bans on everyone
inside the perimeter but if the
incubation period was much longer than
the difficulty of containing the spread
is exponentially higher within two weeks
or more a virus can jump from patient
zero to halfway around the world and
back before the CDC is even aware that
anyone is infected and by that point it
may be too late there will now be
multiple points of origin in various
countries and it suddenly becomes a game
of whack-a-mole with a target that can
multiply and spread to thousands of
people in just hours yet nobody
we'll know who those victims are and to
where it has spread until two weeks
later lastly of course the Z's ex would
need to be incredibly infectious viruses
can spread through the air water touch
the mortal disease X has to spread at
its disposal the deadlier it would be
but what is some maligned entity a rogue
state or terrorist organization could
actually design such a disease from the
ground up
unfortunately they could using current
technology CRISPR is a section of DNA
that genetic scientists can edit and
when combined with a protein called cows
9 the new and edited DNA can be replaced
in living cells to modify any behavior
or physical features of that individual
Chris Peck has 9 editing can be used on
any living organism from bacteria to
cats to humans CRISPR is a new and
exciting technology that could allow us
to effectively alter humanity forever
scientists have already used similar
techniques to edit aquarium fish so they
glow in the dark you can go right ahead
and buy them in pet shops for a fairly
cheap but if extremists mastered CRISPR
there's no reason why they couldn't use
it to edit the RNA or DNA of a deadly
virus to tweak it to their own evil
desires they could for example take
Ebola and remove all visible symptoms
increase its average incubation period
from 10 days to 30 and it could be
adjusted to significantly ramp up its
infectiousness and killing power
essentially this third party whether it
be a terrorist cell or enemy state
during a world war could design and
create the so-called perfect virus with
all the attributes that I mentioned
earlier this would be the world's first
synthetic bioweapon that would easily
affect and kill many millions and if
you're thinking surely if you really
just not jumped in the desert can't edit
DNA you'd be wrong Chris Peck has 9
editing is a relatively simple procedure
is so quick and so cheap
can buy a DIY kit to do it at home for
just over 100 pounds yet despite all
this the world health organization still
doesn't believe that a synthetic
man-made disease poses the greatest
threat to human health the w-h-o has
stated that the greatest biological
threat is highly likely to come from the
natural world
mother nature messes about with CRISPR
billions of times every day
bacteria constantly mutate every single
day roughly 5 million trillion trillion
bacteria on planet Earth undergo the
process of natural selection for
instance when two different strains of
the flu virus meet they cross over and
give each of a new genes and those
attributes and abilities this is how new
flu strains are created creating deadly
viruses is a numbers game and mother
nature plays the numbers trillions of
times per day leaving manmade virus
creators in the dust the mass is against
us as a species
it may come tomorrow or it may come in
10,000 years but the next super virus
that will make Ebola in the Black Death
seem tame is going to come and those
humans are hardly helping matters why
because our antibiotics are about to
fail one out of every three antibiotics
prescribed is unnecessary this is
leading to a global epidemic which the
w-h-o says is one of the greatest
threats to global health food security
and development when antibiotics are
incorrectly or unnecessarily prescribed
they will fail to kill the intended
bacteria in the patient and over a
typical two-week course that surviving
bacteria will learn how to defend
against an antibiotic a little bit
better bacteria does this anyway even
when antibiotics are correctly
prescribed but in such scenarios it
doesn't matter because in those
instances the bacteria will be
eradicated by the antibiotics and thus
it will never get the opportunity to
pass on this new knowledge to the global
bacterial biome
essentially this means that bacteria all
over the world are slowly but surely
becoming more resistant to every
antibiotic one day bacteria may build up
so much resistance that it becomes
immune to antibiotics and that would be
utterly terrifying if this happens we
would have no way of treating infections
such as salmonella pneumonia
tuberculosis and gonorrhea without
antibiotics medicine would be dragged
back to the Middle Ages and a simple
finger cut could be enough to kill you
obviously antibiotics can't kill viruses
anyway we can only vaccinate against
viruses and thankfully vaccines remain
just as effective as always
so how would antibiotic resistance help
a super virus to wipe out humanity well
any lethal virus comes with horrific
side effects such as lesions saws
sickness and diarrhea these are all an
open doorway to infections because of
this people being treated for a powerful
virus are usually prescribed antibiotics
along with their antiviral medicine to
keep infections at bay these antibiotics
are an essential tool to lower virus
mortality rates because without them
even if the virus didn't kill the
patient a subsequent infection may just
finish them off
oh and if antibiotic resistance doesn't
open the doors to a new super virus then
don't worry because the growing number
of shit-for-brains anti-vaxxers are
doing a fabulous job at prepping the
human race for the next pandemic all
this sounds very alarmist but let's be
frank could there be a new disease that
actually succeeds in wiping out all of
humanity no at least the chances are
remarkably low mother Nature has had a
go many times throughout recorded
history and it has never come close to
creating a virus with the potential for
mass extinction not to mention the
thousands of global pandemics during the
two hundred thousand years of unrecorded
prehistory that human beings have walked
the earth there may very well have been
a killer deadlier than the Black deaf at
some point during the enormous time line
if
human race and we just don't know about
it the human race is amazingly resilient
also there is one more traits that would
need to be almost mandatory for a killer
virus to be effective which I didn't
mention earlier to wipe out humanity it
would need to be unfamiliar there are
very few viruses in existence that have
the potential to be mass killers namely
Ebola HIV and influenza in the wild and
then the smallpox hunter virus and
Marburg which are mostly confined to
laboratories a new super virus would
most likely be a new strain of one of
those and it may have infection and
killing powers far superior to the
previous strain but that's not too
concerning here's why microbiologist
have been studying these viruses for
decades we have created complex computer
models that predict exactly how they
will spread government agencies have
created detailed plans on how to contain
any future outbreaks and the medical
field is constantly working on improved
vaccines that will target each of these
threats and since any new strain of say
influenza would have mutated from a
previous strain it will share most of
the same properties so our existing
plans and medical research could be
applied to it yes it may subtly kill a
few hundred a few thousand or
potentially a few million people but
those deaths would mostly hit on
developed nations with poor sanitation
and I'm not for a second trying to say
that that's any less tragic I'm simply
pointing out that once it does hit a
developed nation it will have an
extremely difficult time spreading just
like we saw when Ebola arrived in the
u.s. that is why the biggest threat that
humanity could face would be a brand-new
type of virus not a new strain of an
existing virus but something science has
never come across before that's why the
w-h-o is more concerned with what more
than nature may produce than biohackers
in their garage because biohackers will
need to take an existing virus to modify
it
whereas mother nature has the power to
create completely fresh and original
super viruses
and we have no idea when and where it
could happen next
if disease X does come one day and it
does turn out to be the mass murderer we
all feared then humanity will probably
still survive even when 99.9% of the
human race has been eradicated there
will always be tiny communities in the
mix of the jungle in the frozen
Antarctic wilderness and on boats in the
middle of the ocean that would weather
out the apocalypse just about survived
the pandemic and just as gene therapy
can be used to create new viruses it can
also be used to modify our existing
genetic code to defend the gain step
thanks to rapid advances in CRISPR Kaz 9
research and protein design the day
could soon come when human beings could
be granted immunity to all viruses so
I'm sorry viruses but the human race is
here to stay probably and since the
human race is going to be here for a
little while longer
you can get on with promoting your brand
and building a stylish online presence
and there's only one place you should go
to build a website for your business
Squarespace Squarespace provides an
effortlessly simple set of online tools
to craft your perfect website in the way
you desire I had a go at building a
website for 42 and I was blown away by
how quick and easy it was the results
look modern stylish and importantly
unique to my needs and my vision there
are integrated blogging tools to share
stories photos videos and updates which
is ideal for regular content creators
such as myself if you have an audience
you want to stay in touch with that
Squarespace makes it a breeze you can
add social sharing buttons to your site
with a few clicks you can run email
campaigns to stay in touch with your
customer or contact list like I've done
you can also take bookings and schedule
through your Squarespace sites and
clients can easily see your availability
and reschedule if needed
taking the hassle out of coordinating
calendars head over to Squarespace comm
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch go to Squarespace calm for
words last 42
save 10% of your first purchase of a
website or domain thanks for watching
subscribe for a new video every week and
thanks again to the sponsor Squarespace
don't forget to check them out by using
the link in the description